[Applaudissements]
hola cyber amis,
je suis bruce campbell, vous me connaissez sous le nom de ash
williams, le mec qui a sauvé le monde
du mal, je suis ici pour vous faire part de la
vérité sur la prochaine mort maléfique du
jeu
[Musique]
vous et vos amis ferez équipe
devenez des héros morts maléfiques classiques pour vivre le
cauchemar,
vous utiliserez des mouvements de finition sauvages ou en
déchirerez un nouveau ou si vous n'êtes pas
dans le truc de sauver le monde, nous
avons une autre option
[Musique]
vous pouvez jouer en tant que vil candarian  démon
lui-même
mais qui voudrait faire ça, il serait un
con
avec le pouvoir de possession dans votre
arsenal, vous effrayerez littéralement ces deux bonnes
chaussures à mort,
vous pouvez le faire si vous êtes un con,
que vous choisissiez le chemin de  le mal ou la
droiture que vous jetterez dans des
endroits que vous avez vus auparavant,
vous collecterez des pages du necronomicon,
découvrirez les bandes perdues de personne et
traquerez d'autres artefacts légendaires
lorsque vous en aurez attrapé suffisamment,
vous utiliserez un sort pour envoyer le kendarian
fils de [ __ ] retour au trou de l'enfer
est venu de
[Musique]
bientôt vous vivrez l'horreur
vous-même mais pour l'instant je vais vous laisser avec
cette pensée que
ce n'était pas un hasard si ash portait toujours
un pantalon marron
[Musique]
je vais gâcher ces marchandises